tu alité au sommaire de ce jeudi 9
septembre l'ombre du commandant massoud
qui plane aujourd'hui sur l'afghanistan
20 ans joueront jours après son
assassinat alors que ironie du sort les
talibans ont repris le pouvoir dans le
pays
aujourd'hui qui incarne désormais cette
lutte face aux taliban l'espoir peut-il
renaître avec notamment son fils ahmad
masood ou est-ce peine perdue plusieurs
manifestations ont été interdites
aujourd'hui à kaboul
au sommaire également la politique en
france une décision qui interroge le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
devant deux chaînes de télévision de
décompter le temps de parole du
chroniqueur eric zemmour alors qu'il
n'est pas encore officiellement candidat
à la présidentielle
le csa considère malgré tout que
l'éditorialiste doit être regardée comme
un acteur du débat politique national
pour ses prises de position
que dévoile le baromètre de la pauvreté
publiée aujourd'hui par le secours
populaire l'association indique que la
crainte de basculer dans la pauvreté
après tout la société française dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire 27 pensant
des français se resterait sur leur
quantité de nourriture des français qui
doivent faire face à une hausse des prix
et l'installation justement qui a été un
pic de plus de 1 9% le mois dernier du
jamais vu en trois ans alors comment
expliquer cette poussée soudaine des
prix cette forme est elle une menace
pour le pouvoir d'achat à l'heure où des
voix s'élèvent pour un relèvement des
salaires autant de questions auxquelles
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre tout à l'heure dans son hélico
des éditos échos
et avant d'évoquer la résistance qui
semble vouloir s'organiser non sans
difficultés en afghanistan
on s'arrête quelques instants sur ces
nouvelles tensions entre les états unis
et les talibans washington aurait violé
l'accord de paix de doha signé avec le
mouvement selon ces derniers les
précisions de mourad gazière envoyée
spéciale à kaboul pour rta
internationale
on a beaucoup spéculé au cours des
dernières semaines sur la constitution
du gouvernement fort ni par les talibans
certains espéraient des compromis de la
part des talibans la formation d'un
gouvernement plus inclusif avec
l'intégration peut être deux femmes
comme le demandaient les occidentaux
malgré tout le gouvernement annoncée par
les talibans un gouvernement temporaire
il est purement talibans ils ont
peut-être été encouragés par leur succès
dans la vallée du panjshir le théâtre
des derniers affrontements le dernier
bastion des forces de résistance que les
talibans auraient été écrasées souffler
et contraint à battre en retraite dans
les montagnes
peut-être que ce qui a été vu comme un
succès militaire ordi des talibans le
gouvernement intègre de nombreux
talibans de carrière quatre ministres et
vice ministres d'anciens détenus de
guantanamo bay ainsi qu'un ministre dont
la tête est mise à prix par le fbi pour
5 millions de dollars et qui est
également un fugitif international
17 je crois membres de ce gouvernement
figure sur le liste de terroristes ou
les listes noires internationales
les talibans affirment que les états
unis et promet de retirer ces noms des
listes de terroristes à l'époque des
négociations de paix entre les têtes
loin les états unis à doha la ville où a
été signé l'accord de paix pour mémoire
le coeur de cet accord était le départ
des etats-unis d'afghanistan at-il dit
sion que les talibans garantissent que
l'afghanistan ne servirait plus jamais à
al-qaïda ou à toute rencontre
terroristes internationaux de base pour
des attaques contre l'occident et
d'autres pays c'est le point majeur est
d'accord n'a jamais été rendu public
dans sa totalité il existe des clauses
mineures nous n'avons pas connaissance
la première fois que les etats-unis les
talibans se sont accusés mutuellement
d'avoir violé l'accord doit c'était
lorsque les états unis ont bombardé les
talibans au début de leur offensive
éclair contre les forces du gouverneur
comme il ya quelques mois
des américains ont bombardé les talibans
les talibans ont affirmé qu'il
s'agissait d'une violation des accords
de paix les etats-unis ont riposté
l'attak des villes et capitales
provinciales à avant le retrait des
états unis représentait également une
violation de l'accord
les taliban lui même fait de grands
efforts à kaboul et ailleurs pour
pouvoir espérer une reconnaissance
internationale
ils ont enterré leurs éléments les plus
fanatiques il n'y a pas eu les mêmes
mains de cendres que lors de la prise de
kaboul en 996 il est clair qu'ils
essaient d'obtenir une reconnaissance
internationale
ils ont désespérément besoin de l'aide
humanitaire international et des
financements qui ont été gelés afin de
tenir toutes leurs promesses à la
population afghane
ironie du sort les talibans qui ont
repris a le pouvoir en afghanistan vingt
ans après la mort du commandant massoud
le 9 septembre 2001 deux jours avant les
attaques du 11 septembre à new york
celui qui incarnait la résistance anti
taliban était apte à ce n'est par des
kamikazes d'al-qaïda déguisés en
journalistes
retour sur son combat avec et nicholas
pettit
à la fin des années 1980 il s'est forgé
une réputation de brillant chef de
guerre luttant contre les forces
soviétiques qui occupaient la province
du panjchir c'est aussi depuis cette
vallée située au nord-est de
l'afghanistan que le commandant massoud
a repoussé avec son armée de
moudjahidine les talibans au pouvoir à
partir de 1996 en août 2001 deux
journalistes venus l'interviewer sont
reçus dans la base de quoi jiabao digne
trop occupé ahmad shah massoud n'est pas
en mesure de répondre aux questions dans
l'immédiat et sagement attendu par les
deux hommes comme l'a confié ce proche
du commandant tué dimanche par les
talibans ils ont passé dix jours avec
nous attendant calmement et patiemment
qu'il arrive sans trop insister pour que
l'interview se fasse vite le 9 septembre
2001 l'interview destinés à agrémenter
un supposé documentaire peut avoir lieu
au bout de quelques secondes les pseudo
journalistes font exploser leurs bombes
cachées dans cette caméra gravement
blessé au visage ahmad shah massoud
meurent au cours du trajet qui doit la
mener hôpital après cet attentat suicide
perpétré par deux tunisiens missionné
par oussama ben laden les proches de
massoud préfère cacher sa mort pendant
des jours la disparition du lion du
panchir considéré par nombre d'afghans
comme le dernier espoir face aux
talibans provoquent une onde de choc une
semaine après sa mort ils sont des
milliers à assister à l'inhumation dans
son district natal de bazar ac au
premier rang desquels son fils vingt ans
après alors que les talibans se sont de
nouveau emparé du pouvoir ahmad masood a
repris le flambeau à la tête du front
national de résistance
le fils du célèbre commandant n'a pas
l'intention de capituler et ce alors
même que les talibans sont hissé leur
drapeau dans la région du panjshir lundi
une scène particulièrement forte dans ce
bastion des moudjahidine sur lequel
n'avait jamais été en mesure de mettre
la main durant 40 ans mais à en croire
l'un des frères du commandant massoud
les talibans sont encore loin d'avoir
gagné
ne pensez pas que parce qu'ils ont pris
une route ils ont pris le panchir non il
n'est pas prix le panchir nous avons
encore des milliers de combattants dans
la vallée à tout moment ils reviendront
et vous serez témoin de cela
dans ce contexte néanmoins très tendu
ahmad masood aurait franchi les
montagnes afghanes pour rejoindre le
tadjikistan il a appelé son peuple à se
soulever pour la dignité la liberté et
la prospérité du pays ces derniers jours
des manifestations ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes de l'afghanistan et
justement appel à la résistance entendu
par certains afghans ces derniers jours
on vient de le dire plusieurs
rassemblements de centaines de personnes
pour la défense des libertés ont été
dispersés par des combattants armés
talibans notamment dans la capitale
kaboul certains étaient organisés on l'a
vu la semaine dernière par des femmes en
vain puisque l'application des
restrictions sans se préciser à leur
égard on appris aujourd'hui que les
talibans voulaient interdire
féminines la pratique du sport on fait
le point sur la situation avec maxime a
bola
[Rires]
des scènes à bientôt prohiber la
pratique du sport sera fortement réduite
voire interdite pour les femmes afghanes
interrogé par la télévision australienne
sur un match de cricket est programmée
entre l'australie et l'afghanistan l'un
des responsables de la commission
talibane se montre inflexible
l'islam est l'émirat islamique
n'autorise pas les femmes à jouer au
cricket ou à pratiquer ce genre de sport
où elles sont exposées les femmes n'ont
pas besoin de cet ordre elles pourraient
être exposés ne pas respecter le code
vestimentaire et l'islam ne le permet
pas même si nous sommes confrontés à des
défis et à des problèmes nous nous
sommes battus pour notre religion et
pour que l'islam soit respectée même si
cela provoque une opposition
nous n'abandonnerons pas nos règles
islamiques
les libertés des femmes de plus en plus
réduite dont les universités les
premières réglementations sont
progressivement mis en place et les
cours mixtes vont être interdits
les étudiantes devront se plier à une
organisation spécifique pour ne pas
croiser d'étudiants elles auront
l'obligation de porter le niqab ainsi
que la bahia un large voile qui recouvre
le corps
quant aux cours qu'elles suivront ils
devront tous être assurée par des femmes
un problème car à l'heure actuelle le
nombre d'enseignantes est trop faible en
afghanistan pour subvenir aux besoins
des écoles et universités alors en
attendant une solution certaines
étudiantes peuvent continuer de suivre
des cours de façon mixte mais avec des
rideaux qui les sépare des étudiants
la situation actuelle n'est pas très
bonne comme vous pouvez le voir très peu
d'élèves sont venus surtout défi car
cette situation nous freine nous n'avons
plus la même motivation mais nous ferons
toujours de notre mieux
gaza est d'acheter beaucoup de filles ne
sont pas venus parce qu'elles craignent
pour leur avenir
pour leur retour au pouvoir les insurgés
avaient promis un gouvernement inclusif
pourtant celui annoncé par intérim ce
mardi est exclusivement masculin face au
mécontentement populaire les talibans
veulent temps péri
ce gouvernement est temporaire nous
aurons des postes pour les femmes dans
le respect de la charia c'est le début
mais on fera une place aux femmes elles
pourront faire partie du gouvernement ce
sera notre deuxième étape une
affirmation nuancée par l'un des hauts
dirigeants des talibans
mercredi dernier il a laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait y avoir des femmes au
sein de l'exécutif mais uniquement à des
échelons inférieurs
restrictions à l'égard des femmes
manifestations interdites appel à la
résistance du fils massoud concrètement
comment lutter contre la volonté
aujourd'hui des talibans peut-on compter
sur une nouvelle forme de résistance
notamment en héritage de celui que l'on
surnommé le lion du panchir ou est-ce
peine perdue c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonsoir
egisthe à vos côtés salvatore lombardo
écrivain vous êtes l'auteur de massoud à
massoud ça vient de paraître aux
éditions marei merci également de votre
présence ce soir justement il ya 20 ans
on en parlait le commandant massoud
était assassiné aujourd'hui
régis le sommier la question qu'on se
pose c'est que représentent-ils
exactement dans l'afghanistan
d'aujourd'hui est ce le héros national
comment nous présente souvent vous qui
avez passé encore une fois
le mois de juillet sur place a alors le
commandant massoud reste une figure
emblématique populaire chez les tadjik
qui représente à peu près 30% de la
population au delà aussi il a une aura
dans d'autres compartiments de la
société
ça reste oui une figure importante en
afghanistan mais on peut pas comprendre
l'afghanistan si on comprend pas la
donne ethnique et la zone tribale et il
est évident que dans d'autres ethnies le
commandant massoud n'a pas la popularité
qui peut avoir chez les siens en
particulier chez les hasards à
massoud a été un seigneur de guerre
quand on est un seigneur de guerre en
afghanistan
évidemment on fait la guerre donc on
n'est pas quelqu'un c'est pas un
démocrate entre guillemets à
l'européenne et il a laissé certains
mauvais souvenir pendant ses conquêtes
et pendant toute là la période où
l'instabilité s'était installé en
afghanistan vous me direz elle est là
depuis un moment mais la guerre civile
afghane a été terrible il y avait trois
seigneurs de guerre principaux qui se
partageaient le pays massoud de ce tome
et hekmatyar et ils se sont fait la
guerre parfois ils ont fait des
alliances et tout ça ça a été quand même
sur le dos du peuple afghan et les
talibans ont profité justement de ses
divisions de cette époque là pour
arriver au pouvoir donc voilà le
commandant massoud oui très populaire
chez certains au nid par d'autres
aujourd'hui clairement salvatore
lombardo c'est son fils ahmad qui a
repris qui tente en tout cas de
reprendre avec difficulté certes la
résistance vous voyez beaucoup de
différences entre le père et le fils en
dehors de là je ne vois pas de
différence l'unique différence c'est que
ahmad incarne la nouvelle génération
afghane vous savez vingt années on
passait votre spécialiste 10 et que
massoud c'était il ya vingt ans que les
hasards à etc accessoirement je
m'inscris info pour pas mal de choses
les hasards à faisait partie de la garde
personnelle du commandant massoud il est
réhabilité l'ethnie hazara et il aura au
de redonner une fierté les hazaras a
créé quelques uns c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est un commandant un
seigneur de guerre quand on est un
seigneur de guerre en afghanistan n'est
pas quelqu'un de bleu blanc comme on a
pu le présenter et un certain nombre de
populations moi j'ai passé du temps chez
les haras en février dernier des tests
commandant massoud voilà c'est tout un
temps où les à la normale est incertaine
pas tous mais quand j'ai rencontré sur
le franc à taloqan sous les
bombardements des talibans des hasards
acquis protéger tout ce qu'il pouvait
aucun portrait du commandant massoud
suis désolé vous l'avez dans certains
coûts demeurent à d'acheter le pain frit
pareil donc cesser reconnaissez que
l'afghanistan est quand même un pays
divisé uniquement ou les zones tribales
compte avant tout et que cette vision
démocratique où je ne dis pas la colle à
la personnalité du commandant massoud a
dépassé sa communauté sa joue john je
voudrais fait deux très bien au dollar
dans ses dépenses est une réalité meriem
a concédé c'est une réalité mais le
cobra souverain ce critère rare au nez
c'est que le commandant massoud s'est
comporté parfois comme les autres
seigneurs de guerre pour la cto cdc des
gens qui ont il a dit oui là il a
détruit une partie de kaboul voilà dans
son affrontement et quelques matières
donc tous tous à ccc alors le jeune
maçon c'est intéressant mais c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant parce que ça c'est
un discours pour le coup on n'entendra
jamais sur une autre chaîne qu'ici parce
que c'est vrai que il est présenté le
commandant massoud certainement à bien
des égards à juste titre comme un héros
national
qui est la démocratie les parents sur le
terrain une forme de controverse parce
que la population la diversité afghane
est grande c'est ça ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse la techno
valises l'analyse ethnique c'est une
réalité les lady les différents chefs de
guerre c'est une réalité
ce n'est pas une réalité de croire que
massoud ne fait pas l'unanimité d'un
d'un dans d'autres communautés que la
sienne il ya même des pachtouns qui est
qu'ils aiment massoud il ya des matches
où la technologie
et de la a décrit massoud excusez moi je
vous ai dit c'est parler mais c'est moi
je suis venu pour
moi j'ai passé des mois en afghanistan
s'est pas passé j'ai passé des mois il
ya deux jours j'ai passé des mois
pendant 20 à 25 ans de ma vie d'avant
j'ai pas et j'ai partagé des combats
j'étais sous les bombardements à taloqan
la bataille des batailles sur des
milliers d'autres non mais je parle pas
de moi quand je parle de la capacité de
la presse du tendon d'autres ethnies
auprès des pachtouns excusez moi le
commandant massoud n'est pas la figure
de référence il n'est pas la figure de
référence chez les hazara il n'est pas
la figure de référence chez les ouzbeks
c'est la réalité de l'afghanistan qui
est comme ça vous savez j avais
représente 30% de la population c'est
une technique en
belgique parce que ce serait occulter
l'importance du combat mené à l'heure
actuelle contre toute attente
charlie vient ahmad masood ahmad ahmad
masood contre toute attente pas ce qui
est normal de gens que ça gêne et y
compris chez nos confrères chez nos
confrères journalistes ahmad masood ce
n'est pas l'héritier c'est quelqu'un qui
a su créer une vague en l'espace de deux
années il a créé une vague de sympathie
autour de lui chez nouvelle génération
de d'argan parce que pour beaucoup de
gens comme pour beaucoup de jeunes
français de gaulle ils savent pas trop
ce que ça signifie pour de beaucoup de
jeunes cubain che guevara ou camille le
chien fou et guarin ça parce que ça
signifie pour beaucoup de jeunes afghans
massoud c'est une figure tutélaire
lointaine espèce de statue du commandeur
entouré de deux nuages médiatique on
sait pas trop
ahmad est arrivé un espace de 18 mois il
est arrivé à se constituer un capital de
sympathie pratiquement partout dans le
pays qui est qui est assez exceptionnel
d'après moi d'ailleurs il est arrivé à
fasciner des foules encore davantage que
son père pourquoi peut-être parce qu'il
a un discours plus modéré peut-être
parce qu'il n'est pas un chef de guerre
peut-être parce qu'il est jeune
peut-être parce qu'il propose d'autres
solutions que les solutions
originalement proposé par santerre mais
quoi qu'il en soit il dit dans une
immense fidélité à l'héritage politique
de centenaires et aujourd'hui il propose
une solution originale qui me semble
parfait parfaitement viable et qui
semble parfaite l'amiable d'autres
personnes il ya 48 heures j'étais dans
le cas de la suisse university à genève
pour un symposium sur l'afghanistan avec
mon ami bernard henri lévy et on partage
la même analyse c'est à dire que ce
jeune homme là il incarne face à
l'incohérence des occidentaux face à
l'est une cohérence de l'asie centrale
il impose une figure romantique baroque
et politique qui peut qui peut changer
la donne réellement alors en tout cas
pour le moment il ne l'a pas changé il
ya eu la chute du panchir que lui
reprochent d'ailleurs certains anciens
combattants de son père je vous propose
d'en écouter avant de vous faire réagir
justement
ahmad masood est un patriote mais il est
jeune et n'a pas l'expérience militaire
de son père la chute du punch ir face
aux talibans si son père était toujours
en vie jamais nous n'aurions vu cela on
va continuer peut-être dans cette
polémique mais soudain contre metz n'y a
pas de polémique entre nous disons
le n'est pas tombé complètement ça c'est
une réalité il faut dire aussi que sans
le sens l'appui des hélicoptères
d'attaqué
pakistanais sans l'appui de l'aviation
pakistanaise sans l'appui des drones
fourni généreusement par la turquie
ça n'aurait pas été possible donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à l'époque il
peut se souvenir que les soldats russes
ont pu pénétrer au coeur au coeur du
panchir et mais ils ne sont jamais
parvenus à le conquérir totalement
pourquoi parce que massoud prévoyez des
possibilités de retrait sur des zones
pratiquement inaccessible il compris
dans des défilés inaccessible pour les
hélicoptères de combat son fils a fait
exactement la même chose donc des
anciens combattants disent que si
massoud était là dans les mêmes
conditions massoud aurait fait la même
chose que son fils il aurait demandé à
ses troupes de rompre le combat et de se
retirer sur une deuxième voire une
troisième ligne de défense vous savez
massoud avait une parole et vous la
connaissez vous aussi je suis persuadé
ils disent ils préfèrent perdre du
terrain que perdre des hommes
inutilement c'est le même chose pour
ahmad
aujourd'hui régis le sommier clairement
on voit que cette résistance et appelle
à la résistance d'arman massoud mais
aussi sur le terrain avec les
manifestations des uns et des autres y
compris des femmes peinent à être
entendus et avoir un écho est-ce que
tout simplement cette résistance est ce
qu'elle est perdue d'avancé
aujourd'hui en afghanistan c'est plus
complexe que ça elle est perdre des les
pas perdus d'avancé ce que ce que disait
ce qui était dit tout à l'heure c'est c
est être tout à fait exact l'afghanistan
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas l'afghanistan en
2001 il faut vraiment insisté sur le
fait que kaboul et un certain nombre de
villes même jalalabad même des troubles
et des endroits très conservateurs ont
eu taxes ont eu accès ont fonctionné je
dirais pendant 20 ans au diapason du
monde à kaboul il ya eu des choix y ait
des choses assez triste là tout à
l'heure c'est comment ces peintures
murales qui ont été posées par les
talibans juste avant en juillet quand j
étais sûr c'est juste du source sur les
murs que vous montriez tout à l'heure il
y avait des peintures de médecins des
peintures de jean représentant la
société civile il avait même pas un
taliban un des fameux talibans ce
célèbre avec son rpg et ses yeux verts
et à la place du rpg avait mis un crayon
donc
il y avait une sorte de voile à de
vitalité de la société qui s'exprimait à
travers ses pochoirs sur les murs alors
c'est une résistance qui va pas être
tout de suite une résistance armée mais
c'était vie donc là il ya une opposition
fondamentale entre ce que professent les
taliban et on le voit petit à petit
malgré qu il ya de temps en temps un pas
en avant et deux pas en arrière vous
stimule souligné tout à l'heure que il y
aura peut-être une femme au gouvernement
et c'est a écrit dans le même temps il
ne peut pas faire de sport c'est la
charia et c'est donc certainement eu des
résistances en tout cas des gens
éclairés qui vont rester en afghanistan
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
et a beaucoup moi je connais beaucoup de
gens qui sont encore vraiment très à
risque qui vivent terrés à kaboul parce
qu'ils se sont exprimés parce que on
sait qu'ils ont eu ces opinions là et
que les talibans 2.0 s'ils ont un côté
il irait progrès si c'est qu'ils savent
très bien comment manier les réseaux
sociaux et qui il observe et ils ont
observé quel journaliste avait fait quoi
etc etc donc ça ils ont vraiment une
observation de cette société donc
comment un mouvement de résistance alors
je termine juste là dessus il ya quand
même un son de cloche que moi j'ai
entendu le à kaboul auprès des
chauffeurs de taxi etc c'est que il ya
une telle lassitude de la guerre que ses
42 ans de guerre qu il ya des gens qui
vous disent bas si les talibans arrivent
à faire un proche de la paix on est prêt
à aller avec les talibans c'est 100 et
même une fois là c'est quarante deux ans
de guerre l'afghanistan vous vous posez
la question des gens ou leur demander
est ce que la paix c'est quoi pour vous
ils savent pas quoi vous dire ils n'ont
jamais connu ça et ça parce que ces
clapets vous vous restez avec nous s'il
vous plaît messieurs puisqu'un premier
vol 1 c'est aussi ça d'actualité
aujourd'hui a décollé de kaboul vers
l'étranger depuis le retrait américain
d'ailleurs à washington en dessous ligne
félicite les talibans pour voir leur
coopération à leur flexibilité ce soir
200 étrangers évacués
on va retrouver justement thomas bonnet
en direct de new-york bonsoir thomas que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur cette
évacuation venait aujourd'hui
et bien 200 personnes ont donc quitté
l'afghanistan à bord d'un avion d'une
compagnie aérienne du qatar c'est le
premier vol vous l'avez dit depuis le
retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan à la fin du mois d'août à
bord de cet appareil des américains mais
aussi des canadiens des allemands ou
encore des hongrois ce vol a donc quitté
kaboul à destination de doha la capitale
du qatar et au delà du soulagement pour
ceux qui attendaient leur évacuation
d'afghanistan c'est aussi un signe
d'espoir pour une reprise des vols
commerciaux dans le pays et d'ailleurs
l'opération a été saluée par la maison
blanche qui a publié un communiqué pour
souligner la coopération et la
flexibilité des talibans
considérant cela comme un premier pas
positif l'envoyé spécial du qatar à
kaboul a lui parlé d'un jour historique
tandis que le responsable technique de
l'aéroport se dit confiant sur le
travail mené pour remettre remettre en
état de marche
cet aéroport de kaboul vous propose de
les écouter
pour la première fois il va y avoir un
vol international de doha kaboul c'est
un vol commercial ou charter peu importe
comment vous l'appelez
le point important c'est qu'il aura des
passagers étrangers et locaux qui
voyagent de kaboul à doha et de doha à
leur destination finale
cette partie de l'aéroport où des
techniciens qatari travail est presque
terminée nous serons très contents
lorsqu'ils auront terminé leur travail
si dieu le veut l'aéroport sera prêt
pour des vols normaux rapidement
et thomas c'est dans ce contexte que
vont se dérouler samedi les
commémorations des 20 années du 11
septembre après leur très chaotique de
l'armée américaine d'ailleurs joba et
d'année et cibler un à l'occasion de ces
commémorations sa présence n'est pas
toujours souhaitée par certains
oui absolument vous avez les critiques
on va dire attendu de la part de
l'opposition républicaine mais ce qui
est un peu plus nouveau c'est que vous
avez aussi des critiques qui sont
formulées ces derniers jours par des
proches de victimes des attentats du 11
septembre je pense notamment à la soeur
du pilote qui a été tué le pilote qui
était au sein de l'appareil qui a été
détournée contre le pentagone et bien eu
des mots très durs contre joe biden elle
reproche au président américain de
laisser l'afghanistan aux mains des
talibans c'est un peu le même son de
cloche chez un certain nombre de proches
de victimes et certains d'entre eux ont
même explicitement demandé à ce que joe
biden n'assiste pas à ses commémorations
samedi que ce soit à new york ou à
washington il faut noter que ce n'est
pas la première fois que des proches de
victimes des attentats du 11-septembre
demande à joe biden ne pas se rendre aux
commémorations puisque ces dernières
semaines il y avait eu à des appels en
ce sens de la part d'autres familles de
victimes qui avaient cosigné une lettre
ils sont 1800 et dans cette lettre il
demandait à joe biden doit faire toute
la transparence sur les différentes
enquêtes autour de ces importants de ces
attentats il reproche notamment qu'on
n'est pas vraiment d'informations sur le
financement et sur le rôle présupposés
de l'arabie saoudite dans ces attentats
du 11 septembre alors depuis joe biden a
indiqué que des documents allaient être
déclassifiés sans qu'on ne sache
réellement quelles informations vont
être rendus publics mais en tout cas le
contexte et l'atmosphère est
particulièrement lourde pour le
président américain au moment de
commémorer donc c'est décennie depuis
les attentats du 11 septembre merci à
thomas abonné je me tourne vers vous à
nouveau rêver se souvenir vous avez
aussi été correspondant à washington
plusieurs années c'est vrai que le
timing est vraiment assassin pour joe
biden son retrait américain et ses
commémorations du 11-septembre tout à
fait parce que pour les américains
particulièrement le 11 septembre c'est
les tours les tours qui fument les les
tours dans les ruines et beaucoup
d'américains se souvient de george bush
tu as eu le lendemain des attentats qui
va rencontrer les pompiers de new york
et il ya un pompier qui lui dit on ne
vous entend pas il leur parle et vous ne
vous entend pas monsieur le président et
lui prend un échafaud nez il dit je
ferai en sorte que ceux qui ont fait ça
nous entende et cette promesse et cette
guerre contre le terrorisme
définie par bush à l'époque on se rend
compte que vingt ans après qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il ya eu cette guerre de
nécessité qui a été la guerre afghane où
l'amérique est intervenue pour chasser
ben laden et al qaïda et puis cette
guerre de choix des dirigeants
américaine qui était la guerre en irak
mais ces deux guerres ces deux
investissements ont mené à quoi un
retrait précipité d'irak en 2010 ce qui
permet l'émergence de dèche et
aujourd'hui on leur donne les clés aux
talibans exactement au même que vous
qu'on était venu chasser 20 ans avant on
peut se poser la question aujourd'hui à
ton gagner cette femme fameuse guerre
contre le terrorisme moi je crois que
non et justement je voulais vous faire
écouter une phrase glaçante c'était en
avril
2001 cinq mois avant ces attaques la
phrase évidemment été prononcée par le
commandant massoud écouté mon message au
président bush est le suivant les
problèmes auxquels nous faisons face
seront bientôt ceux des américains et du
reste du monde
sanader est lombardo plus que
visionnaire commandant massoud on se
souvient de cette phrase clairement on
se retrouve aujourd'hui dans la même
situation vingt ans après ce que cette
phrase est toujours d'actualité on
pourrait la transposer la même situation
empire
vampires d'après moi
pourquoi parce qu'il ya 20 ans il ya des
choses qu'on ignorait aujourd'hui on
sait certaines choses on sait par
exemple que on parle d'un gouvernement
d'un pseudo gouvernement fantoche des
talibans alors qu'il existe un
gouvernement légal en afghanistan la la
la la fuite de la fuite pitoyable de
ashraf ghani le président afghan n'a pas
mis fin au gouvernement afghan le
gouverneur afghan légales existent
toujours la constitution afghane prévoit
en effet que en cas de vacance de la
présidence et le premier vice président
qui devient président jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les nations unies n'ont pas
reconnu des talibans et reconnaissent
toujours le gouvernement afghan dont le
président l'heure actuelle s'appelle
andrew la salle est ainsi née chef des
services secrets de massoud premier
vice-président dont nouveau président
qui combat les talibans aux côtés de
ahmad masood open cheer voilà ça c'est
la réalité donc moi je moi je suis
vraiment pessimiste je sais pas si mon
confrère les ou pas mais moi je suis
extrêmement pessimiste parce que je
pense que nous nous retirons exactement
les mêmes erreurs mais avec des
conditions aggravante parce que nous
savons aujourd'hui que la politique qui
a été menée en afghanistan contrairement
à ce que réclamaient le combat massoud
et une politique
l'élite littéralement meurtrière pour
les idées de démocratie que nous
prétendons
exportés vers vers l'asie centrale est
noté notamment vers vers l'afghanistan
ça ça c'est vraiment très important
pourquoi allons-nous commettre les mêmes
erreurs qu'il y avait un temps pourquoi
n'avons nous pas entendu le commandant
massoud il ya 20 ans pourquoi le
président chirac et le et le premier
ministre lionel jospin a refusé de leur
de le recevoir lorsqu'il est venu à
paris alors qu'il venait de recevoir des
ministres talibans et pourquoi
aujourd'hui engageons-nous pas le
dialogue avec ahmad masood directement
pour moi ça me semble absolument une
cohérence ça me semble suicidaire
un mot défunt régime rapide où je pense
qu'on assiste plus globalement
au désengagement des américains de
certaines régions du monde là c'est le
centre de l'asie bientôt ce sera mon
quasiment certain la zone enfin le moyen
orient l'irak et la syrie les états unis
tourne aujourd'hui lance de leurs yeux
vers la chine et vers l'extrême orient
c'est pas nouveau ça mais ce qui est ce
que ça provoque ça va être justement la
montée en puissance d'autres puissances
entre guillemets régionales ou
internationales mais avec des velléités
on voit les chinois sont déjà ont déjà
pris langue depuis très longtemps avec
et et ont acté cette victoire des
talibans même avant qu'elle soit
effective donc il ya une neuro il ya il
ya une redéfinition du monde dans
laquelle l'occident a nettement moins de
place les français on n'a plus tellement
voix au chapitre on peut toujours faire
des déclarations d'intention et autres
mais concrètement rien à qui sont déjà à
la manoeuvre les turcs les iraniens les
pakistanais depuis longtemps mais
aujourd'hui on a les chinois et les
russes qui reviennent voilà il avait
quitté l'afghanistan ils iraient la
queue entre les jambes en 88 et
aujourd'hui son lard à nouveau merci en
tout cas tous les deux pour ce débat
intéressant passionnant salvatore
lombardo et et régis le sommier merci à
vous deux
et direction le maroc est présent ou les
islamistes au pouvoir ont été sévèrement
battus au profit de partis libéraux
selon des résultats provisoires des
législatives organisées hier le parti de
la justice et du développement passe de
125 sièges à 12 conséquence de cette
déroute historique la direction du parti
islamiste dont le chef du gouvernement
en sortant annonce ce soir sa démission
cyrielle bruit
revers cinglant pour le pjd à la tête de
l'exécutif depuis plus de dix ans le
parti islamiste de la justice et du
développement s'incline face à son rival
libéral le rassemblement national des
indépendants
pour le porte-parole du parti vainqueur
ces résultats provisoires témoigne d'un
besoin de renouveau au sein du royaume
chérifien admise par tous et qui d'un
almarai rébellion ces résultats prouvent
que les marocains souhaitent aujourd'hui
le changement et veulent une alternative
et nous pensons que le parti
rassemblement national des indépendants
et cette alternance
son programme électoral qui a présenté
aux citoyens et qui a trouvé un bon écho
chez eux lors de la campagne électorale
du côté du pjd c'est la douche froide le
parti passe de 125 sièges dans
l'assemblée sortante à 12 des élections
législatives régionales et communales
entaché par des soupçons de corruption
nous suivons avec une vive inquiétude le
déroulement des élections au niveau
national nous avons relevé plusieurs
irrégularités avant le début du
dépouillement le parti islamiste a
pointé du doigt des irrégularités et
dénonce la distribution d'argent à
proximité de certains bureaux de vote
des accusations balayées d'un revers de
main par le ministre de l'intérieur
marocain abdelouafi laftit tla sûr
hormis des cas isolés les opérations de
vote se sont déroulées dans des
circonstances normales une chose est
sûre cette élection marque un tournant
majeur pour le maroc sous le signe de la
nouveauté de la réforme et de projets
comme l'a promis le roi mohamed 6 au
pouvoir depuis 22 ans
et on va plus loin avec hassan alaoui
directeur de maroc publication
diplomatiques bon soir à sanaa
bienvenue une autre dans notre émission
ce soir le pjd est au pouvoir depuis dix
ans s'est littéralement effondré lors de
ces législatives a organisé hier comment
vous expliquer cette déroute
spectaculaire
c'est tout à fait c'est plus qu'un
effondrement c'est la descente aux
enfers franchement est ici
le sommes d'autant plus
surpris
vraiment effaré que ce parti il n'y a
pas encore il ya 24 heures était donné
comme gagnon encore une nouvelle fois
c'est à dire que l'américain à jeudi
rempiler n'est ce pas il a gagné les
élections aux il a gagné ensuite
deuxième fois cette élection et jusqu'à
l'ariège avancé qu'il n'allait pas se
laisser battre comme ça si facilement
c'est le cas de le dire bien sûr les
ceux qui perdent un accès plus jamais la
réalité mais aujourd'hui ce vote nous a
donné beaucoup d'indications et en
l'occurrence le désir désir de
changement de l'internet comme anti
l'alternance en raison du mode
démocratique bien sûr parce que c'est
dans ce sens que les gens sont allés
voter il faut pas oublier qu'il ya quand
même presque 8 millions de gens qui sont
pour vous qui sont partis voté hier
c'est à dire
car ils m'ont presque 2 millions en plus
de plus et surtout des jeunes qui en
portait un petit peu l'estocade aux
partis religieux et donc pourquoi parce
que s'ils voulaient les parties de jeux
d'hier de libéraux qui sont en créant en
quoi les situant implicite avant je dire
avant le voc ont utilisé les
technologies nouvelles
je vous internet et beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de technique pour moi
évidemment toucher les jeunes et toucher
les populations et bien sûr le pjd l'a
pas accepté l'acceptera pas du tout
jusqu'à jusqu'à nouvel ordre la
prospérité non ce soir hassan alaoui de
graves irrégularités dont la
distribution d'argent à proximité des
bureaux de vote en c'est ce qu'ils
disent en tout cas
certainement qu'il y a qu il ya de
l'argent mais c'est comme dans toutes
les élections ils ont tous les pays on a
dit la même chose pour ronald important
pour train pour vous états unis on le
dit aussi fier en france compterait du
président français et évidemment on ne
peut pas contrôler ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y avait une commission dans
pratiquement des jeux dire des gens qui
sont vérifier la régularité et la
transparence
les observateurs des droits de l'homme
des membres du parlement européen
et français en l'occurrence et qui
endeuillèrent validé et encore
aujourd'hui validé les résultats et donc
évidemment ils ont beau parler les gens
publicité parce qu'ils ont eu quand même
gagné la mise cependant deux fois et
personne n'a contesté
le résultat il est vrai que maintenant
il ya des placements sociologique si
vous voulez du lectorat marocain en ce
sens que les gens veulent bétonner un
peu plus de jeu dire de deux raisons de
vivre des conditions d'existence qui
leur permette d'en affronter la crise
économique
en l'occurrence la colite et donc les
plans les plans qui sont proposés par
les partis le bureau sont des plantes
est évidemment inscrivent si vous voulez
l'économie et les besoins essentiels des
populations dans leurs priorités nous
affrontons aujourd'hui
le coc vide mais nous sommes aussi sur
le poids si vous voulez de m j'allais
dire en oeuvre un plan ambitieux qui
s'appelle le nouveau modèle de
développement
rapidement hassan alaoui dernière
question le roi mohamed 6 1 devrait
désigner dans les prochains jours la
personnalité chargée de former voilà on
a perdu à sanaa we do do l'arrêt brutal
effectivement de l'interview voilà
c'était en tout cas ce n'est la wii
directeur de la publication maroc
diplomatique merci à lui
en france à présent l'actualité
politique dès ce soir le temps de parole
d'eric zemmour est officiellement des
comptes et le chroniqueur n'est pourtant
pas encore officiellement candidat à la
prochaine présidentielle mais pour le
csa éditorialistes doit être regardée
comme un acteur du débat politique
national pour ses prises de position on
retrouve notre reporter monaco dès lors
devant le cfa bonsoir mona amoud et
laure envers et contre tout haut ses
news on décide de garder finalement eric
zemmour à l'antenne malgré la demande du
csa de décompter son temps de parole
alors même si rien n'est officiel eric
zemmour laisse planer le doute quant à
une élection quant à une candidature
pour l'élection présidentielle pourtant
ce n'est qu'une rumeur pour le moment
rien n'est confirmé mais le csa insiste
estime que zemmour est un acteur
politique pour prendre sa décision le
gardien don de visuel s'est appuyé sur
plusieurs points notamment les
intentions de vote dans les sondages ou
encore ses soutiens qui ont affiché
plusieurs les affiches dans toutes les
rues de la ville par ailleurs le
principe du décompte ne se limite pas
seulement à des candidats déclarés à des
élus ou a même des membres de partis
politiques mais à toute personne n'étant
identifié comme eto'o ayant un rôle
actif dans le rôle dans le débat
politique selon la charte du csa est
presque comme un candidat eric zemmour a
déclaré être ouvert à rencontrer marie
le pen ou même avoir un débat avec eric
zemmour qui sont tous les deux candidats
à l'élection présidentielle ce qui sème
encore plus vous l'imaginez le doute or
l'entourage d'eric zemmour est
catégorique et ballet est cette
hypothèse de candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
celui qui a été condamné en 2011 pour
provocation à la haine raciale a répondu
sur twitter hausse concernant à la
décision ou la demande plutôt du csa je
cite je ne me tairais pas selon lui sa
profession de journaliste protège sa
liberté d'expression en toutes
circonstances en tout cas à la demande
du csa et bien elle divise la classe
politique notamment à droite louis
alliot marie du rassemblement national a
estimé que le csa n'a pas à s'immiscer
dans ce genre d'affaires il appelle même
eric zemmour à soutenir marine le pen à
partir du 17 septembre eric zemmour
entamera une tournée dans toute la
france pour la promotion de son nouveau
livre de quoi continuer à cultiver une
certaine ambiguïté et de quoi également
entretenir le mystère sur la suite des
événements merci mona amoud et l'or et
cette décision du csa qui divise on
l'aura compris au sein de la sphère
politique
une censure pour certains notamment pour
le principal intéressé une décision
attendue pour d'autres pour en parler
nous sommes avec stéphane rozès
politologue
bonsoir stéphane rozès merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
est ce que le csa fait de la politique
sur ce coup là stéphane rozès
par la force des choses d'autres un pays
comme le nôtre est en démocratie
au fond dès qu'on prend une décision
décline à sedan ce indépendante même
indépendante prendre une décision en
matière c'est forcément eu aucune vision
politique mais là la question est
la décision est elle fondée en droit
alors le csa ce puits sur la loi léotard
du 30 50 86
et
constate qu'eric zemmour
comme essayiste et d'aujourd'hui un
acteur du débat politique national
et considère qu'ils doivent des comptes
et au fond comme candidat or il y a
quand même un problème
c'est que eric zemmour n'a pas
formellement
déclarer sa candidature
à la présidentielle d'une part et
d'autre part c'est un éditorialiste et
donc oui c'est brahy prendre des
positions politiques me c'est vrai on
est dans une zone un peu grise
ni sentiment pendant quelque temps qui
arrive du monde savait pas très bien
s'il irait ou pas
ces derniers jours on a le sentiment que
oui va y aller sauf que le csa est une
instance indépendante
qui doit juger en droit est le seul
critère c'est et réalisé mourra
technique je suis candidat à la
présidentielle il ne l'a pas fait
stéphane rozès parce qu'il ya eu des
déplacements pour commémorer de gaulle
son éditeur a dit qu'il le reprenne son
contrat car il aurait déclaré vouloir se
lancer dans la présidentielle donc c'est
vrai comme vous dites c'est une zone
grise qui est peut être compliqué à
gérer pour le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
bas et le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel surtout city
et à trancher sur une zone grise à
partir de quels arguments ici ça vous
font de la difficulté
notamment sur le fait qu'eric zemmour
est testé dans les intentions de vote
l'ancien patron d'un institut de sondage
que je suis sait bien que on va tester
dès qu'il ya une probabilité
que quelqu'un soit candidat oui mais
formellement il n'est pas candidat et
donc il ya une suspicion et c'est ça qui
est pas bon au fond c'est de faire
passer moi comme victime ya du coup une
suspicion d'un deux poids deux mesures
employées et c'est ça qui est très
gênant au fond dans cette décision
puis c est ça effectivement c'était ma
prochaine question ce risque de
victimisation y at il réellement et on
peut se poser la question légitimement
aujourd'hui une spécificité zemmour on
sait voilà les sondages dont vous
parliez lui crédite de 7 points alors
qu'il n'est même pas officiellement
candidat on sait qu'il peut gêner aussi
bien à droite mais un peu moins droite
aussi xavier bertrand marine le pen
c'est c'est là que vient la grande
attention qu'on lui porte peut-être plus
qu'un autre
alors je crois qu'il ya une première
spécificité
c'est qu'eric zemmour et d'un
éditorialiste c'est un journaliste et
donc son métier basse et d'intervenir
dans les médias et comme il a des succès
des succès d'audience de librairies et
bien de quoi il existe ou pèse et en
france où la beac le journalisme
politique et les éditorialistes
fonds au fondre de l'analyse politique
alors pas forcément partisane mais ils
font de l'analyse politique donc la
singularité moi c'est d'abord au départ
que c'est internet donc il est dans les
médias ça concerne donc effectivement
dans le fonctionnement de sortie n'est
pas d'inégalité ça concerne le csa mais
là en l'occurrence de c'est sa tranche
une zone grise mais c'est pas le rôle du
csa de trancher n'est ce pas une grille
ns c'est pas le road ne cessa de dire
moi tu considères c'est saccharine
zemmour est candidat à la présidentielle
puisqu'il n'a pas dit qu'il était
candidat par contre comme beaucoup
d'éditorialistes mais plus que d'autres
eric geboers et bien un acteur du débat
politique national si
l'intéressé parle de 200 / est ce que ça
peut donner cette impression justement
aujourd'hui dans un climat de défiance
de la population d'une certaine
population avec le pouvoir
si de serre qui est au fond c'est ça qui
est chez nous parce que dans cette
décision le csa ouf on fragilise sa
légitimité d'homme en effectivement une
perception de l'opinion à l'égard des
médias ça date pas d'aujourd'hui où on a
le sentiment que les médias dépend à la
fois des intérêts économiques mais aussi
du pouvoir politique et dans un contexte
où ces derniers mois pour des raisons ni
terres pour des raisons politiques pour
des raisons diverses
il ya dans toute une partie importante
de la population au fond l'idée que les
libertés serait rené homier et
qu'emmener serait au fond de limiter la
possibilité
d'expression de désaccord de
mécontentement you donc tout ça en plus
se fait effectivement dans un climat où
l'opinion publique peut avoir le
sentiment à mon avis la plupart du temps
à tort mais qu'il y a tout un système
qu'il contrôlerait tout dans la vie
politique
en ce sens je ne comprends pas comme un
analyste cette décision du csa merci
beaucoup stéphane rozès que nous avoir
apporté en tout cas votre analyse ce
soir merci à vous et politiques toujours
avec agnès buzyn qui est convoqué demain
par la cour de justice de la république
l'ex ministre de la santé qui avait
démissionné en février 2020 pour se
porter candidate à la mairie de paris
risque une mise en examen pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui des charges
dans le calme et une enquête menée début
depuis juillet 2020 sur la gestion
gouvernementale de la crise du coc vides
et alors que de nouvelles manifestations
qui passe sanitaires sont encore prévues
samedi la contestation contre le
document controversé se poursuit en
pleine semaine illustration hier à
grenoble avec un rassemblement devant la
bibliothèque municipale reportage signé
luis carballo avec robin pu l
des bibliothécaires en colère contre le
pass sanitaires depuis le 24 août une
partie des employés des bibliothèques de
grenoble sont en grève une mobilisation
renforcée par l'extension du passani
terre pour les 12 17 ans à partir du 30
septembre
malgré les menaces de sanctions les
agents protestent contre une mesure
qu'ils estiment injuste pour moi il ya
vraiment une aberration en fait cette
mesure le ps a été à supprimer dans les
centres commerciaux la prière est en
continuelle contrôlé dans les
bibliothèques donc à un moment donné
voilà la consommation crime sur le
tourne tout le reste et que c'est pas la
société en fait dans laquelle j'ai envie
d'évoluer ça me convient pas donc je
pense qu'à un moment donné il est temps
de marquer son opposition et voir
s'opposer à des mesures fermes
des agents veulent également éviter la
confrontation avec des usagers
mécontents et parfois agressifs une
situation difficile qui pourrait même
être prolongée puisqu'olivier vers ans a
évoqué le maintien du passani terre au
delà du 15 novembre
dans ce contexte toujours incertain
les représentants syndicaux soutiennent
ce mouvement social
passé par le rôle de contrôler
police et c est ça engendre bien sûr des
risques des risques psychosociaux et
c'est pas aux agents de justifier cette
incurie du gouvernement a géré cette
crise sanitaire et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout du gouvernement aux
collectivités territoriales et aux
entreprises en fait ce
désengage de cette responsabilité et le
fort porté en fait sur les travailleurs
et sur les agents du service public la
contestation s'étend désormais à
d'autres villes comme lyon ou toulouse
certains grévistes ont même émis l'idée
d'organiser une journée de mobilisation
nationale pour tous les employés de
bibliothèques et y aura-t-il une
nouvelle nuit de violences ce soir à
corbeil-essonnes le calme à n'aura pas
duré en tout cas longtemps dans le
quartier des tarterêts après cinq soirs
d'émeutes de jeudi à lundi puis une de
cannes mardi un véhicule de police a été
pris pour cible par de nombreux
individus hier soit médiers ce qui fit
des tirs de mortiers des poubelles
incendiées ou encore des jets de
cocktails molotov et de boules de
pétanque voici un aperçu des violences
urbaines qui secoue plusieurs quartiers
de l'essonne depuis presqu'une semaine
notamment dans les communes de corbeil
essonnes et de grigny violence en
essonne caillasser chargé attaqué le
quotidien des policiers dans le quartier
des tarterêts depuis six jours peine
alternative ou prison ferme pour ces
professionnels de l'ensauvagement à
l'origine de ces tensions la publication
d'une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux le 2
septembre une séquence dans laquelle on
voit une mère de famille visée par du
gaz lacrymogène lors d'une intervention
des forces de l'ordre des violences qui
depuis n'ont cessé de s'amplifier
mobilisant 95 policiers dont 39 crs dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi
certains élus de droite ont fait part de
leur indignation
stop ce ne sont pas des millions d'euros
qui remettront l'ordre dans nos cités
mais une justice implacable qui éradique
la voyoucratie avec laquelle on
s'inflige de cohabiter territoires
perdus zone de non droit où d'un autre
droit sécession les émeutes urbaines de
plusieurs jours sont tellement banal
aujourd'hui qu'elles ne font pas ou plus
la une de la presse pour apaiser les
tensions la mairie de corbeil-essonnes a
organisé une table ronde ce lundi entre
des maires du quartier et des
responsables de police une médiation qui
reste quasi impossible pour le moment
malgré la tentative de dialogue amorcé
par ce collectif de mères de famille ce
qui est arrivé n'est pas normal
nous ne voulons pas de georges flooded
adama traoré à corbeil on ne veut pas
que nos jeunes fassent des bêtises mais
on est aussi contre la brutalité
policière
le dialogue n'ayant pour le moment pas
abouti les forces de l'ordre redoutent
une nouvelle vague de violences dans les
jours à venir en attendant une autre
réunion est prévue la semaine prochaine
pour tenter d'apaiser les tensions
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
de secours populaire qui lance un cri
d'alerté sur l'augmentation de la
pauvreté selon le dernier baromètre 20%
des personnes interrogées déclarent
sauter certains repas alors qu'ils
n'étaient que 14 % en 2020 la crise du
comité seul responsable nous tenterons
en tout cas d'y répondre
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terrorisme est-ce que vous
êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui
a été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda est aliments ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent y va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre devoir moral que de venir en
aide à ce peuple qui a souffert tant par
le passé
il
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire connaître le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
public il est clair que tout le monde
attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livrant
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime pour qu'on parle de jay liste
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants on parle de gens qui sont d'une
barbarie extrême c'est vrai que c'est un
terreau qui peut favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam s'étant
bien mac sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours mon l'adversaire
même si je méprise totalement son
idéologie comme c'est le cas pour sega
liste
ep
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité on est comme tout le
monde sur les pentes appartement on est
énervé donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à
chaque fois se battre ils vivent parfois
au bord des routes nationales pas
forcément loin de paris mais toujours
loin de ceux qui les dirigent moi je
voudrais pas qu'on ait passé un tour de
tracteur avec mouscron campagne il faut
savoir c'est une vie différente ils ont
le sentiment d'être des français de
seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission que des
voix le baromètre de la pauvreté publiée
aujourd'hui par le secours populaire
l'association indique que la crainte de
basculer dans la pauvreté imprègne toute
la société française dans ce contexte de
crise sanitaire 27 pensant les français
doivent se restreindre sur leur quantité
de nourriture des français qui doivent
faire face à une hausse des prix la
station justement qui a atteint un pic
de plus de 1,9 pour cent le mois dernier
du jamais vu en trois ans alors comment
expliquer cette poussée soudaine des
prix cette flambée est elle une menace
pour le pouvoir d'achat à l'heure où des
voix s'élèvent pour un relèvement des
salaires autant de questions auxquelles
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre dans quelques instants dans son
édito est comme
[Musique]
un sondage réalisé par ipsos et de
secours populaire publié ce jeudi
montrent une augmentation de la
précarité en france depuis la crise du
coc vide le chômage les privations
encore les pertes de liens sociaux
touchent une part de plus en plus
importante de la population
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
et
on
quand on est parent cela veut dire se
priver régulièrement y compris de
nourriture pour ses enfants sans parler
des vacances loisirs ou même coiffeur
qui sont inaccessibles
[Musique]
si la crise n'a pas occasionné un
basculement d'ensemble de la société
elle a fragilisé sans doute durablement
nombre de ses composantes au delà des
personnes déjà fragilisées par leur
position précaire salariée ou
indépendante la déstabilisation des
stable aura en toute probabilité lieu
mais de manière différée
des pauvres de plus en plus pauvres donc
en france selon le secours populaire
alors que le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'est lui ai récemment
une performance exceptionnelle de
l'économie française on en parle tout de
suite dans notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
bruno parmentier consultant et
spécialiste en questions alimentaires en
direct avec nous par skype bonsoir bruno
parmentier une autre avec nous sur ce
plateau henri sterdyniak économiste
membre des économistes atterrés bonsoir
henri sterdyniak merci d'être là alors
ce sont des chiffres évidemment alarmant
publié notamment par l'insee 1 cette
semaine regarder un français sur cinq en
situation de pauvreté monétaire ou de
privation matérielle et sociale en
métropole c'est ça la crise du coc vie
de henry sterdyniak qui est responsable
de tout ça ou c'est un un raccourci
c'est un raccourci un le le taux de
pauvreté en france est de l'ordre de 15%
il a sans doute augmenté en 2020 ils
devraient ils devraient se retrouver un
niveau de l'ordre de 15% en 2021
lorsqu'on regarde l'enquète du secours
populaire français bien sûr il ya
toujours entre 30 et 40 % de gens qui
déclare se priver pour aller en vacances
pour aller aux coiffeurs pour certains
même se priver de nourriture mais il n'y
a pas de très forte dégradation par
rapport à la situation de 2019 il ya ce
que la crise a quand même montré c'est
la fragilité d'une partie de la
population à on a bien vu les précaires
les marginaux et puis aussi ce qui a été
très frappant les étudiants entre qui
n'ont pas de prestations dédiées entre
18 et 25 ans avant de donner la parole
évidemment à bruno keip parmentier tout
de même vous bon c'est pas
nécessairement que la crise sanitaire
par rapport à 2019 mais est-ce que ça a
tendance parce que c'est la question
qu'on se pose toujours à empirer d'année
en année où finalement pas tant que ça
au fil des décennies on ça n'empire pas
d'année en année le fait est que il est
apparu de nouvelles précarités
en particulier liées au marché de
l'emploi les intérimaires les personnes
en cdd les personnes en sous traitance
toute la gamme si on peut dire des faux
auto entrepreneurs ce sont des gens qui
sont fragiles et qui vont tomber dans la
précarité dès qu'on a un choc comme le
choc du coc vie d'anna une prayssac
d'une protection sociale qui est très
généreuse mais on a des trous les 18
23 ans qu'on a oublié alors qu'eux ils
accèdent de plus en plus tard un emploi
stable et puis je le répète le
développement de la précarité qui est
une conséquence de la flexibilisation de
l'emploi alors cette estimation de
l'insee on peut là l'a confirmé en
recoupant certaines informations comme
celles fournies par l'institut de
sondage ipsos 1 dans son baromètre
publié par le secours populaire
regardez 20 % des français souhaitent un
français sur cent déclarent sauter
certains repas références parfois ou
souvent alors qu'ils étaient 14 % en
2020 bruno parmentier vous le
spécialiste des questions alimentaires
c'est évidemment inquiétant vous l'avez
constaté vous aussi sur le terrain et
qu'est-ce que ça reflète
oui alors relativisons la crise du coc
vite puisque réchauffement climatique
bus les conflits c'est que la faim dans
le monde augmente de façon considérable
en ce moment mais la vraie fin c'est les
gens qui meurent de faim je vous
rappelle que ya à peu près un enfant qui
meurt de faim toutes les 10 secondes sur
la planète et oxfam a estimé que
la fin grandi qu il va y avoir à peu
près onze personnes qui vont mourir
à la minute au lieu de au lieu de
5,6 avant et 7 pour le coc vide donc la
faim tue plus que le coc vite maintenant
forte heureusement à corbeil qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure personne ne meurt de faim
ce dont on parle en france c'est des
restrictions des pénuries mais c'est pas
la fin au sens que
un risque vital alors maintenant tv
repas part parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens de voile à le manger non plus
correctement à sa fin à chaque repas
voilà maintenant nous sommes un des pays
du monde de plus solidaire et on a vu
quand même pendant cette crise qu vide
que le l'idée de quoi qu'il en coûte a
quand même été impressionnante par
rapport à d'autres pays maintenant ça
n'est pas parce que on indemnise les
gens qu'on met au chômage parce que on
oblige les magasins où les usines de
fermer qu'on couvre l'ensemble du
problème on il ya tout un tas de tron
alors ben les étudiants font plein de
petits boulots ya plus de petits boulots
ils ont plutôt en plus on ferme le
restaurant universitaire les étudiants
de manche pour pas cher ils sont obligés
de compenser ça coûte plus cher mais
c'est pareil on a fermé les cantines des
écoles pendant un moment ben les gens
aux revenus modestes
mettent leurs enfants à la cantine et le
repas qu'ils payent coûte beaucoup moins
cher que ce que ce cas chez eux donc
toute cette frange cette marge qui est
difficile à saisir
s'estompe et les coûts augmentent
moyennant quoi les gens ont l'impression
de sombrer dans la pauvreté est ce qu'on
voit c'est que le secours populaire le
secours catholique les restaurants du
coeur ont beaucoup plus de clients qui
n'ont jamais eu alors que justement ils
ont du mal à s'approvisionner parce
qu'ils s'approvisionnent surtout sur les
gâcher de la société alors quand il ya
moins de grossistes camp il ya moins de
restaurants etc il ya moins de gâchis
donc c'est vrai qu' il ya d'un côté ce
succès extraordinaire qui est que la
solidarité sociale en france a été
exemplaire depuis deux ans et en même
temps une société a toujours des marges
et c'est très difficile de de compenser
ses marges donc il ya ces deux choses
l'économie repart mais tous ces petits
boulots et cetera toute cette économie
plus ou moins souterraine n'ont pas
encore redémarré donc nous sommes dans
une situation où les gens sont frustrés
parce qu'ils ont l'impression de devenir
beaucoup plus pauvres effectivement
notre invité vient de faire référence à
nos ministres de l'économie qui est
annoncé partout que l'économie avait
repris des couleurs 6% de croissance
cette année 4% l'année prochaine selon
les prévisions de bruno le maire
c'est le figaro qui titrait ce matin les
pénuries de main d'oeuvre un peu partout
alors évidemment c'est toujours
compliqué de le dire sur un plateau tv
s'en aller vérifier mais c'est ce qu'on
nous dit en tout cas c'est un discours
en en trompe l'oeil de la part de bercy
qu'est ce qui cloche enfin en tout cas
expliqué nous cette cette perspective qu
on a du mal à avoir noah disons que
c'est un discours un peu en trompe
l'oeil un camp dit il ya 6 % de
croissance c'est pas 6% de croissance en
fait c'est une des simplement un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui en raison de la
crise que vides étaient fermés petit à
petit elle rouvre que ce soit des hôtels
cafés restaurants les salles de sport
des boîtes de nuit et naturellement ça
augmente le pib il faut savoir
qu'actuellement il nous manque environ 5
% d'activité par rapport au niveau
normal qu'on aurait eu 100 la crise est
naturellement ça se traduit par le fait
que les ja de sureffectif dans l'est
dans les entreprises on a eu une
politique extrêmement généreuse de
chômage temporaire qui fait qu' il n'y a
pas eu d'augmentation du ya pas eu
d'augmentation du chômage donc trop que
tant mieux
le en 2020 le revenu global des ménages
n'a pas chuté malgré une chute du pib de
l'ordre de
9% donc la situation
n'est pas si mauvaise
l'activité repart
et dans un certain nombre de secteurs au
contraire on s'aperçoit que il ya des
pénuries de main-d'oeuvre parce que les
entreprises n'ont pas anticipé de façon
correcte la reprise donc elle se
retrouve à chercher des qualifications
qui n'existent pas par exemple dans
l'informatique dans un certain nombre de
secteurs les entreprises continuent à
proposer des emplois trop mal payés avec
des conditions de travail trop mauvais
dont ils ont du mal à les allait fournir
tout ça s'est relativement satisfaisant
ça prouve que le marché fonctionne et on
a eu aussi
disparition d'un certain nombre
d'emplois précaires mais d'autres
emplois précaires ont bizarrement été
créée par exemple toutes les livraisons
à domicile c'est la situation et il faut
dire que par rapport à 2020 en 2021
quand même il ya un certain nombre de
facteurs de pauvreté qui ont disparu
puisque les écoles et les cantines
remarche c'est ce que nous disait bruno
parmentier bruno parmentier
ce quoi qu'il en coûte et surtout sa
faim dont nous parlait henri sterdyniak
vous la craignais justement vous malgré
ces belles prévisions de croissance oui
enfin il faut toujours regarder les
chiffres sur un peu à long terme quand
l'économie a baissé de 9% et qu'elle
remonte de 6 ça fait quand même moins 3
donc je veux dire faut plusieurs années
pour retrouver les situations d'avant
qui n'était pas génial bon donc
effectivement on a encore probablement
une à deux années qui vont être
difficiles donc c'est normal les gens
qui sont aux affaires disent regardez sa
part mais ça avait beaucoup chuté avant
effectivement il ya des gens qui ne veut
plus qu'ils ne veulent plus faire le
métier d'avant et puis il ya beaucoup de
petits métiers bon parlait de la
livraison à domicile qui sont quand même
très pénible et très mal payés bon on a
vu par exemple au printemps 2020 les
frontières se sont se sont fermées on
sait pour les sens donc on importe deux
cent mille personnes de l'étranger pour
récolter nos fruits et légumes bon on a
dit ben c'est pas grave les gens sont au
chômage ils vont tous allés récupérer
les fruits et légumes et ça fait pschitt
parce que c'est les métiers extrêmement
pénible vous êtes évidemment très mal
logés et vous êtes très mal payés et
donc en bombant heureusement après bomba
les étrangers sont revenus rama chaîne
aux pommes énorme et nos asperges mais
bon il va falloir forcément que le
marché acceptent d'augmenter les
salaires des métiers pénibles et des des
petits boulots on va dire qu'ils
régulent un peu le le l'ensemble de
l'activité donc tout ça ça va créer des
tensions sociales pendant six mois un an
deux ans en plus on est en électorale
donc ça va être un petit peu compliqué
mais globalement quand on baisse de 9%
et qu'on augmente de 6 c'est pas génial
de dire ce qu'est ce que c'est bien
regarder cette croissance oui bon
d'accord ben on était tombé très bas
donc on est en train de rattraper
seulement on n'a pas fini de rap le
modef parce qu'on arrive à la fin de
notre débat il faudra un moment donné
comme le suggère bruno parmentier
augmenter les salaires de ces petits
boulots effectivement pénible
mal m'en effectivement il faudrait
augmenter ses salaires il faudrait
améliorer les conditions de travail à la
fois dans le secteur public et dans le
secteur privé la france jusqu'à présent
comme on l'a dit s'est reposé sur les
travailleurs immigrés fraîchement
immigrés et sur les étrangers à qui on
pouvait confier des travaux mal
rémunérés et et pénible effectivement ce
serait bien que on revalorise ces
métiers de manière à ce que
effectivement ça devienne des débouchés
pour les travailleurs français si je
puis dire merci à vous en risque
indignez-vous nos par vanter d'avoir été
avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage
sur effectivement des chiffres qui
parfois ne veulent pas dire grand chose
il faut les mettre en perspective merci
à vous
et une gestion par l'exécutif de la
crise sanitaire dénoncé par certains
français justement c'est le cas
notamment des lises pena une
travailleuse sociale il s'oppose au pass
and it erp notamment et pour faire
réagir la femme entamé une grève de la
faim il ya dix jours en occitanie
reportage signé axel thomass avec un des
grands champs
ils étaient une vingtaine ce mercredi
matin à parcourir 25 km entre toulouse
et en dînant haute garonne une marge de
près de huit heures en soutien à nice
pena en grève de la faim depuis dix
jours opposent et aux passes sanitaire
cette travailleuse sociale militante est
soutenu par ses collègues amis et même
par des inconnus sensible à son combat
en fait on voulait rendre public
son action qu'est personnel et du coup
encourager aussi peut-être d'autres gens
à faire des actions peut-être pas aussi
les limites que and is parce que elle
seule peut le faire là parmi nous moi je
ne suis pas capable de faire ça voilà et
dès que ça passe pas en fait ce qu'on
voulait c'est que ça passe pas elle fait
pas ça pour la gloire donc voulais que
ça soit médiatisé
médiatisée c'est faire une marche
solidaire
on est tous contre ce pas sanitaires
quand j'ai totalement liberticide en
fait eh bien on a apporté notre soutien
parce que c'est vraiment très courageux
de sa part c'est une initiative qui est
qui est très belle je trouve l armée
beaucoup de courage elle travaille en
plus en parallèle donc ça lui prend
beaucoup d'énergie aussi donc voilà on
est là la solidarité comme maître mot
l'objectif étant de donner de la
visibilité la démarche d'anne lise qui
s'oppose fermement à cette mesure
gouvernementale à travers son refus de
s'alimenter
j'espère un mouvement collectif
important
notamment de
de ma profession du médico social que je
trouve quand même difficile à mobiliser
mais
j'en appelle à tous le personnel de
santé et du médico-social à à s'unir à
ne pas avoir peur on est en train de de
vivre un tournant on prend un virage je
sais pas comment va le prendre mais il
faut qu'on résiste à 7 à cette privation
de liberté de choix
ça me paraît incontournable
les agents publics salariés et
personnels des établissements sanitaires
et médico sociaux ont jusqu'au 15
septembre pour se faire administrer au
moins une dose de vaccin anti qu'ovide
en cas de non respect de l'obligation
vaccinale
les salariés pourront être suspendues
sans rémunération et des français qui
devrait faire face à une hausse des prix
qui s'accélère dans le pays avec un pic
de plus de 1,9 pour cent en août du
jamais vu en trois ans l'inflation un
phénomène général en cette période de
reprise posco vide alors comment
expliquer cette poussée soudaine des
prix cette flambée est elle une menace
pour le pouvoir d'achat quels sont les
risques de stagflation c'est-à-dire
l'inflation sans croissance une fois
l'euphorie de la reprise passait on voit
cela tout de suite avec l'économiste
jacques sapir c'est notre rubrique
l'édito échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
alors cette inflation dont on parle est
ce que finalement c'est un phénomène
purement français où ça concerne
d'autres pays également alors oui vous
avez tout à fait raison de parler de
cette accusation au départ non c'est un
phénomène général on le voit par exemple
au niveau des états unis qui sont
actuellement à 5,4 pour cent d'inflation
s'ils voulaient c'est énorme parce que
il était pratiquement à zéro au mois de
janvier on le voit en europe dans
l'union européenne
ou on est pour les prix industriels
autour de 2,3 pour cent et on le voit
aussi en france avec un taux d'environ
29% alors un jacques pour la france donc
quelle est la situation précisément
alors pour l'un pour la france si vous
voulez la situation c'est la suivante on
n'a eu pratiquement une inflation qui a
fortement baissé dans l'année 2020 et
qui a commencé à redémarrer à partir de
janvier février de cette année alors ça
peut se comprendre on a eu les
de confinement de 2020 ça a évidemment
casser complètement l'activité ce qui
est quand même intéressant c'est de voir
que quand l'inflation repart le
troisième confinement ne l'affectent pas
et évidemment depuis la sortie du 3ème
confinement là l'inflation suivant les
chiffres de l'insee accélère et comme je
le disais elle atteint maintenant 1,9
pour cent alors quels sont les produits
qui ont le plus contribué à cette
inflation alors comme en europe qui a
évidemment une hausse assez sensible des
produits industriels mais ce qui est
intéressant dans le cas de la france
c'est de voir que les produits agricoles
des produits alimentaires aussi ont
monté de manière assez conséquente est
là encore si on se réfère à l'insee il y
à une hausse d'environ 10% mais je
dirais à partir d'un niveau qui était
effectivement très bas au départ
d'environ 10% depuis sept huit mois donc
là aussi il y a un effet d'inflation qui
est très nette évidemment la question
qu'on pose pourquoi de thanos oui
évidemment c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser alors d'abord il faut savoir il
y à des ruptures de production ou plus
précisément la demande est repartie
beaucoup plus vite koné repartiez la
production sa cause des phénomènes de
pénurie et ses pin rives dame en font
monter les prix c'est le cas
particulièrement des semi conducteurs il
ya aujourd'hui plusieurs usines en
allemagne et en france qui sont au
chômage technique à cause de cette
question après il ya un problème global
de hausse des matières premières et sa
touche et ça c'est intéressant toutes
les matières premières qu'il s'agisse
des matières premières agricoles
problème en france mais qu'il s'agisse
aussi du pétrole qui est passé de
environ 40 dollars le baril au début de
cette année à 70 dollars actuellement et
les métaux enfin il ya un problème que
l'on a tendance à négliger mais qui est
très important c'est la désorganisation
des modes de transports la
désorganisation de la logistique il ya
des porcs qui ont été bloqués à cause de
la crise de l'aco vide en chine en
particulier et on voit que le prix du
transport est en train d'augmenter très
fortement alors c'est intéressant
effectivement mais vous ne parlez pas de
la politique des banques centrales est
ce qu'elle aurait quelque chose à voir
maintenant je vous vois effectivement la
politique des banques centrales elle
joue mais elle ne joue pas sur cette
inflation elle va jouer beaucoup plus
sur l'inflation de ce qu'on appelle les
actifs patrimoniaux alors lancé actifs
patrimoniaux évidemment les actions les
obligations et on voit bien aujourd'hui
le marché de paris comme l'ensemble des
marchés financiers est un des plus hauts
historiques
mais ça touche aussi par exemple le prix
des logements et là un phénomène qui est
assez intéressant on voit que bon double
que ce soit les les appartements ou les
maisons tout cela ça a monté depuis sept
huit mois aujourd'hui les appartements
stagne voire reubess un petit peu
pourquoi parce que les gens à cause des
confinement se disent on n'a pas envie
d'être confiné dans un appartement on
veut pouvoir acheter une maison si
possible avec un petit terrain pour que
les gosses puissent jouer etc et là on
voit que le prix des maisons augmentent
de manière très sensible alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure est ce qu'il ya
un risque de stagflation
clairement aujourd'hui comme certains le
redoutent et on en parlait oui alors
effectivement faut d'abord rappeler que
la stabulation c'est une situation où on
a de manière combinée une inflation
forte et une croissance nulle ou
extrêmement faible alors aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le risque le plus évident pour
deux raisons la première raison c'est
que évidemment on voit bien qu'il ya des
causes techniques à cette inflation et
puis la deuxième raison c'est que il ya
toujours un chômage qui est assez
important en particulier en france mais
c'est quand même aussi vrai largement en
europe et tant qu'il y aura ce chômage
on peut penser qu'il n'y aura pas de
cesse d'en voler
des salaires et des coûts salariaux
maintenant l'autre problème c'est que
cette inflation elle détériore le
pouvoir d'achat et en particulier le
pouvoir d'achat des salariés les plus
faibles parce qu'il faut bien voir que
dans la hausse moyenne des salaires que
l'or a connu malgré tout malgré
l'épidémie eh bien elle est tirée par
les salaires les plus élevés et les
salaires du médian inférieur autrement
dit elle ils ont inférieurs à la moitié
et bien soit ils sont restés sable soit
ils ont baissé donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire bien ça veut dire que le
gouvernement va être sous une pression
très forte d'une part pour augmenter de
manière substantielle le smic et puis
d'autre part et ça c'est aussi un
problème qu'il faut relier je dirais aux
pénuries de main-d'oeuvre qu'on a
sectoriellement ainsi vous voulez parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'entreprise qui soit
aujourd'hui en france bloquée par manque
demandeur mais on a des pénuries qui
sont qui peuvent apparaître de manière
relative sectoriellement et bien il va y
avoir nécessairement une hausse des
salaires dans les mois qui viennent
l'inflation donc à surveiller comme le
lait sur le feu je me bats avec vous
jacques sapir merci à vous et à très
bientôt et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi rendez
vous dès lundi prochain 20 heures
évidemment et prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera dans une trentaine
de minutes excellentes fin de soirée à
tous
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse
d'industriels extrêmement contre les
coupables puisque on reverse 50 5 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à
la commune ils sont donc très intéressé
au fait que le fonctionnement soit line
ont fait exactement comme les banques
les compagnies d'assurance parce qu'il
ya des gens suspects nous sommes dans
l'obligation de déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dedans